so there's a lot of valid concern these
days that our technology is getting so
smart that we put ourselves on a path to
a jobless future and I think the example
of the self-driving car is actually the
easiest one to see so these are going to
be fantastic for all kinds of different
reasons but did you know that the driver
is actually the most common job in 29 of
the 50 US states what's going to happen
to these jobs when we're no longer
driving our cars or cooking our food or
even diagnosing our own diseases well a
recent study from Forrester Research
goes so far to predict that 25 million
jobs might disappear over the next 10
years to put that in perspective that's
three times as many jobs lost in the
aftermath of the financial crisis and
it's not just blue-collar jobs that are
at risk on Wall Street and across
Silicon Valley we are seeing tremendous
gains in the quality of analysis and
decision making because of machine
learning so even the smartest
highest-paid people will be affected by
this change what's clear is that no
matter what your job is at least some if
not all of your work is gonna be done by
a robot or software in the next few
years and that's exactly why people like
Mark Zuckerberg and Bill Gates are
talking about the need for
government-funded minimum income levels
but if our politicians can't agree on
things like health care or even school
lunches I just don't see a path where
they'll find consensus on something as
big and it's expensive as universal
basic life income instead I think the
response needs to be led by us in
industry we have to recognize the change
that's ahead of us and start to design
the new kinds of jobs that will still be
relevant in an age of robotics the good
news is that we have faced down and
recovered to mass extinctions of jobs
before from 1870 to 1970 the percent of
American workers based on farms fell by
90% and then again from 1950 to 2010 the
percent of Americans working in
factories fell by 75%
the challenge we faced this time however
is one of time we had a hundred years to
move from farms to factories and then 60
years to fully build out a service
economy the rate of change today
suggests that we may only have 10 or 15
years to adjust and if we don't react
fast enough that means by the time
today's elementary school students are 8
car college age we could be living in a
world that's robotic largely unemployed
and stuck in kind of an ungraded but I
don't think has to be this way you see I
work in innovation and part of my job is
to shape how large companies apply new
technologies certainly some of these
technologies are even specifically
designed to replace human workers but I
believe that if we start taking steps
right now to change the nature of work
we can not only create environments
where people love coming to work but
also generate the innovation that we
need to replace the millions of jobs
that we lost to technology I believe
that the key to preventing our jobless
feature is to rediscover what makes us
human and to create a new generation of
human centered jobs that allow us to
unlock the hidden talents and passions
that we carry with us every day but
first I think it's important to
recognize that we brought this problem
on ourselves and it's not just because
you know we are the one building the
robots but even though most jobs with
the factory decades ago we still hold on
to this factory mindset of
standardization and D skilling we still
define jobs around procedural tasks and
then pay people for the number of hours
that they perform these tasks we've
created narrow job definitions like
cashier loan processor or taxi driver
and then ask people to form entire
careers around these singular tasks
these choices have left us with actually
two dangerous side effects the first is
that these narrowly defined jobs will be
the first to be displaced by robots
because single task robots are just the
easiest kinds to build but second we
have accidentally made it so that
millions of workers around the world
have unbelievably boring working lives
let's take the example of a call center
agent over the last few decades we brag
about lower operating costs because
we've taken most of the need for brain
power out of the person and put it into
the system for most of their day they
click on screens they read scripts they
act more like machines than humans and
unfortunately over the next few years as
our technology gets more advanced they
along with people like clerks and
bookkeepers will see the vast majority
of their work disappear to counteract
this we have to start creating new jobs
that are less centered on the tasks that
a person does and more focused on the
skills that a person brings to work for
example robots are great that repetitive
and constrained work but human beings
have an amazing ability to bring
together capability with creativity when
faced with problems that we've never
seen before it's when everyday brings a
little bit of a surprise that we have
designed work for humans and not for
robots our entrepreneurs and engineers
already live in this world but so do our
nurses and our plumbers that therapists
you know it's the nature of too many
companies and too many organizations to
just ask people to come to work and do
your job but if your work is better done
by a robot or your decisions that are
made by an AI what are you supposed to
be doing well I think for the manager we
need to realistically think about the
tasks that will be disappearing over the
next few years and start planning for
more meaningful more valuable work that
you replace it we need to create
environments where both human beings and
robots thrive I say let's give more work
to the robots and let's start with the
work that we absolutely hate doing here
robot process this painfully idiotic
report and move this box thank you and
for the human beings we should follow
the advice from Harry Davis at the
University of Chicago he says we have to
make it so that people don't leave too
much of themselves in the trunk of their
car I mean human beings are amazing on
weekends think about the people that you
know and what they do on Saturdays
they're artists carpenters chefs and
athletes but on Monday they're back to
being junior HR specialists systems
analyst three
you know these narrow job titles not
only sound boring but they're actually a
subtle encouragement for me people to
make narrow and boring job contributions
but I've seen firsthand that when you
invite people to be more they can amaze
us with how much more they can be a few
years ago I was working at a large bank
that was trying to bring more innovation
into its company culture so my team and
I designed a prototyping contest that an
invited anyone to build anything that
they wanted we were actually trying to
figure out whether or not the primary
limiter to innovation was a lack of
ideas or a lack of talent and it turns
out it was neither one it was an
empowerment problem and the results of
the program were amazing we started by
inviting people to re-envision what it
is they could bring to a team this
contest was not only a chance to build
anything that you wanted but also be
anything that you wanted and when people
were no longer limited by their
day-to-day job titles they felt free to
bring all kinds of different skills and
talents to the problems that they were
trying to solve
we saw technology people being designers
marketing people being architects and
even finance people showing off their
ability to write jokes we ran this
program twice and each time more than
400 people brought their unexpected
talents to work and solve problems that
they had been wanting to solve for years
collectively they created millions of
dollars of valuing things like a better
touch-tone system for call centers
easier desktop tools for branches and
even a thank you card system that has
become a cornerstone of the employee
working experience over the course of
the eight weeks people flexed muscles
that they'd never dreamed of using at
work people learn new skills they met me
they met new people and at the end
somebody pulled me aside and said I have
to tell you the last few weeks has been
one of the most intense hardest working
experiences of my entire life but not
one second of it felt like work and
that's the key for those few weeks
people got to be creators and innovators
they had been dreaming of solutions the
problems that had been bugging them for
years
and this was a chance to turn those
rheems into a reality and that dreaming
is an important part of what separates
us from the machines for now our
machines do not get frustrated they do
not get annoyed and they certainly don't
imagine but we as human beings we feel
pain we get frustrated and it's where
we're most annoyed and most curious they
were motivated to dig into a problem and
create change our imaginations are the
birthplace of new products new services
and even new industries I believe but
the jobs of the future will come from
the minds of people who today we call
analysts and specialists but only if we
give them the freedom and protection
that they need to grow into becoming
explorers and inventors if we really
want to robot proof our jobs we as
leaders need to get out of the mindset
of telling people do what to do instead
and start asking them what problems
they're inspired to solve and what
talents they want to what bring to work
because when you can bring your Saturday
self to work on Wednesdays you'll look
forward to Monday's more and those
feelings that we have about Mondays are
part of what makes us human and as we
redesign work for an era of intelligent
machines I invite you all to work
alongside me to bring more humanity to
our working lives thank you
[Applause]